areas
so I've been practicing that a lot yeah
it's a welcome you to Lancaster house or
this Justice ministers conference thank
you and your team for making today
possible I'm delighted we're also joined
by Kareem Khan Chief prosecutor at the
international criminal court
and particularly our friends from
Ukraine a Minister of Justice Denise and
prosecutor General Andrew costume this
is very much a conference to express our
solidarity and support for you and the
Ukrainian people as well as the
independent work conduct by the ICC
um it's also good to see friends here
today representing 42 nations from
around the world according to Nations
but United in one cause which is to hold
the Russian government to account for
the horrific atrocities committed in
Ukraine during its unjust unprovoked and
unlawful War
we come together as that Invasion enters
its second year a war that has brought
unimaginable suffering to the people of
Ukraine
we continue to stand with Ukraine as
they Brave you resist this naked
aggression
and I think it's absolutely vital that
we support the people of Ukraine in
their efforts to safeguard their country
and secure a free Ukraine not just for
them but for the cause of democracy
around the world and for the basic
principle of the rule of international
law which unites us today
that is the principle why we're all here
today and that is what we hope to
achieve in the hours that are before us
at this meeting to uphold the
international rule of law
to reject impunity and to provide
accountability for the worst crimes
against the international order
last year of course we stood together we
made a state party referral to the ICC
37 countries initially joined us in
referring the situation in Ukraine and
now it's supported by 43 States I
believe in total many of whom have
joined us at this conference today
that is of course the largest referral
in the icc's history
it's a clear marker lay down of our
International and Collective resolve
and crucially from a practical point of
view it has enabled Kareem Khan and his
team to launch their investigation into
the atrocities in Ukraine more quickly
Expediting the Court's legal processes
and moving one step closer to justice
for the Ukrainian people
on Friday the ICC issued an arrest
warrant for President Putin and his
children's rights commissioner over the
alleged Abduction of hundreds of
Ukrainian children taken forcibly from
their parents and deported to Russia
so I think we can feel and say that it
is a historic moment for the war in
Ukraine
and it underlines the vital importance
of the ICC and the office of the
prosecutor as an independent prosecutor
of war criminals
and it sends a much stronger and more
far-reaching message right around the
world to despots and dictators
everywhere that they will be brought to
justice but they will be held to account
and as we come together today
I hope and I believe it serves to
underline the importance of ensuring
that the ICC has every support for the
crucial work that it is doing
now on top of and in addition to the ICC
work of course alongside the US the
European Union the UK has been involved
in establishing the atrocity crimes
Advisory Group and together we're
supporting Ukraine's prosecutor General
in his domestic investigation and
prosecution of war crimes and we're
doing that with funding but also
technical expertise and can I take the
opportunity to applaud the work already
done in that field with more than 70 000
potential war crimes cases recorded so
far
that includes the support that we're
providing vital training for the
Ukrainian judges and prosecutors
responsible for overseeing war crimes
and I think it's fair to say given the
scale of the judicial challenge that we
see that we need those efforts to go
hand in hand they're complementary uh in
a practical sense as well as in the
sense that the ICC sets out
and if we're going to turn the lofty
concept of accountability
into practical and concerted action for
the people of Ukraine and the victims of
this appalling War we need that
partnership to work effectively
and that's why I'm pleased that there
are so many countries uh represented
around this table today
we all believe that all criminals must
be brought to Justice
we're all committed to the Practical
means to achieve those goals
my friends
together we have led efforts to support
the icc's investigation in Ukraine we
share the belief that President Putin
and The Wider leadership must be held to
account and it's absolutely vital that
we unite behind the ICC and that we
support the office of the prosecutor
with whatever it needs whether it's
resources whether it's technical
expertise to continue with all of its
investigations and of course we're
particularly focused on Ukraine but
we're ever mindful of The Wider mandate
that Kareem and the team is pursuing
so in closing let me just say that the
discussions we have today and the
commitments that we make will serve to
strengthen the chief Prosecutor's hand
enabling him and his team to bring those
responsible for war crimes in Ukraine to
Justice and let's make sure that we back
up our words with Deeds that we back up
our moral support with practical means
to effectively investigate these awful
crimes we owe it to the Ukrainian people
and frankly we owe it to all around the
world who suffer under this kind of
brutality so thank you for coming and
I'll now hand over to Dylan who is
co-hosting with us and thanks again to
the brilliant Dutch team for all their
efforts
I'd like to start of course by thanking
our host Deputy Prime Minister Dominic
Rapp and his team for bringing this
impressive group of people together
on the first day of the war president
zielinski addressed the Russians and
told them in their own language if you
attack us you will see our faces not our
bags
for the Russians this was a message of
warning for ukrainians a message of
defiance and for us
Ukraine's allies a message of
encouragement we were already
compassionate but those words filled us
with admiration
and revealed to us the heart of the
Ukrainian people
but the message was also a promise that
had yet to be fulfilled
a Fearless declaration that was easier
said than done
especially as time passed and the most
horrific crimes were being perpetrated
against civilians in cities like
borodianca and mucha and Villages like
sevchenko and lozova
it wasn't only military bases or arms
Depots that were being attacked no it
was also residential areas and public
parks where until recently Ordinary
People would take a stroll or play with
their children
after more than a year of heavy fighting
the ukrainians are still showing their
faces and their courage
and they have no intention of abandoning
their country
men and women both conscripts and
volunteers have taken up arms to defend
their country
and courageous young people are using
social media to Galvanize the world
before the war their online videos were
about makeup and cars but now they are
posting images of bummed out buildings
and showing the disgraceful way the
Russians are trying to take control over
their cities and Villages these young
people are asking the outside world
asking us
for help
meanwhile women are providing food and
places to sleep in air raid shelters
and grandmothers are suing camouflage
outfits for all those brave Soldiers at
the front
ukrainians of all ages are giving it
their all and using every means at their
disposal to firmly defend their Homeland
they are motivated by love of their
country
but we realize all too well that they
are not just doing it for themselves
they are also doing it for us
because here in the UK on the continent
and around the world our freedom and our
security are at stake
if we fail to draw the line now where
will it end
Russia's hopes that Ukraine would simply
collapse were dashed
in fact the opposite happened
Ukraine showed Unity
and now we must show Unity too
together we must take responsibility for
making sure that the perpetrators of
these crimes are prosecuted together we
must establish the truth achieve Justice
and ensure security
immediately after the invasion the
international criminal court began
Gathering and securing evidence
field investigators analysts and
forensics experts now have no time to
lose
especially as we are hearing more and
more reports of summary executions
torture sexual violence forced transfer
of children and destruction of Civilian
infrastructure
your presence here today supports the
ICC in its mission to punish
perpetrators of international crimes
worldwide
and I say worldwide because although the
war in Ukraine is the reason for our
meeting today there are many other
active armed conflicts around the world
with the victims of those conflicts in
mind we fully support the icc's broader
mission
the Netherlands confirms a strong
support for the ICC
the ICC is at the center of our effort
for the investigation and prosecution of
core International crimes
for the ICC to fulfill this Mission it
is of utmost importance that state
parties provide adequate resources
through the regular budgets
complementary to the regular budget
states can also provide voluntary sport
which comes in many forms
such as knowledge expertise equipment
and funding
and all of these resources are equally
valuable
last year for example a Dutch forensic
investigation team took part in the
icc's largest Mission ever
Professor Bella cubot was a member of
the team
as a forensics expert she believes she
has a duty to help bring war crimes to
light
and I believe that such dedication
highly is highly recommendable
especially if you consider that during
the team's mission in May and December
the missile attacks continued Non-Stop
more missions will be conducted in the
spring and Autumn if this situation
allows
wouldn't it be terrific if we if the
speed of our Collective action and
investigations could serve as a
blueprint for future ICC investigations
so we are doing all we can
we cannot close our eyes when Horrors
like these are unfolding
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
the Ukrainian people have shown us more
than once that they will have the last
word on their future
they are battered but never broken
angry and frustrated but never defeated
and together with Ukraine we are drawing
the line
together with Ukraine we will make sure
that there is no impunity for the rich
Russian invader
together we will do everything in our
power to ensure that justice prevails
and that the perpetrators of the most
heinous crimes are held accountable
together with Ukraine we are striving
for justice security and peace thank you
thank you very much Dylan very well
spoken can I now ask
his Excellency Kareem Khan the chief
prosecutor of the ICC uh to speak to us
thank you
uh Deputy Prime Minister
Minister of Justice of the United
Kingdom Minister of Justice of the
Netherlands firstly thank you so much
for all the effort to convene this
important occasion and really to all of
you to have so many
um
senior State officials from all
continents of the world Fiji Ghana
Ecuador Japan South Korea that have come
not for anything other than to emphasize
that human rights the Dignity of the
individual
are something that engage each and every
one of us and in this moment of
crisis
and I don't think that's hyperbole
when we are on a precipice of stability
or even worse configurations
I do think this is a particularly
important moment to talk about the
relevance of the law and the
international criminal court as the
world's only permanent criminal
jurisdiction that is dealing with basic
elements of humanity the prohibition of
genocide crimes against humanity and war
crimes I wish to applaud all of you
particularly the Minister of Justice of
Ukraine the prosecutor general of
Ukraine for their wonderful support so
each of us has an important role to play
and I think that really the foundation
of this conference how can the law not
only in Ukraine but more widely be
rendered more effective less theoretical
and that requires each of us to play a
part I think in the midst of Despair
suffering has and heroism
there is a sign for optimism I'm
fortunate to be sitting next to Didier
renders and the European commission and
quite honestly I'd heard a lot about
bureaucracy and red tape but they moved
very quickly in a way to support us to
move forward
but we need to have collectively the
stamina to deliver on Justice this
moment
of a Reawakening
has some promise within it
that finally we can vindicate the
suffering of the Holocaust of the
Balkans of Rwanda of Cambodia of Sierra
Leone where we've heard in conference
after conference a magnificent wonderful
historical settings like this that we
will have a world for our children of
Never Again
well that will only be possible by your
own efforts and the continued support
that we've seen
now I've said in different for us and my
friends from Ukraine have heard me say
it in New York and elsewhere
I'm a friend of the Ukrainian people but
I'm also a friend of the Russian people
we are friends of humanity we are
friends of legality in what we oppose
our actions which are deemed to be
Criminal
criminals since Nuremberg
and of course
on Friday the judges of pre-trial
chamber 2. assess the results of the
investigation that the office is being
carried carrying out under the
leadership of principal lawyer Brenda
Hollis who sits behind me in the
Fantastic work of the team over these
last months
that's been
fortified
by secondments by working with national
Partners to make sure we don't just
whisper
Pious nothings but we show those that
need it the most that the law provides
shelter even as their own shelter is
decimated under bombs that cause massive
demonstration but it's a moment of
not for triumphalism
not for
any
backslapping
it is really a very sad occasion and a
very somber occasion
that for the first time
ever judges of the international
criminal court
of any Court have felt it necessary to
issue warrants against a leader and
Senior State officials from a permanent
member of the security Council
that our Founders that have wonderful
histories
but also that are supposed to be
Guardians of the U.N Charter
so that apolitical evidence-led
investigation is the Hallmarks of my
office and it is the condition it is the
absolute indispensable element for any
judicial process that will stand the
test of time
the allegations are serious indeed and I
said in butcher in in April that Ukraine
was a crime scene many types of
allegations have been received
and to anybody who says well what seems
to have taken place is humanitarian
evacuation
um
the evidence
may tell a different story the judges
have said so but I say repatriate the
children
return the children
reunite the children
if there is any semblance of Truth
to the utterances that this is for the
sake of children instead of giving them
a foreign passport return them to the
countries of their nationality instead
of teaching them a foreign language let
them learn their own language in their
own schools instead of being in
unfamiliar environments with permanent
adoptions by strangers bring them back
to their communities their families I
mean they have families many of these
individuals
two weeks ago I was in
close to the front line in the south of
Ukraine
and I went to one of these orphanages
and Care Homes and the juxtaposition
between
the photographs that were still adorning
walls
of
Christmas Past
Nativity plays with children smiling and
carers looking after them but joyous
and the sometimes basic but beautiful in
all their basic and crudity paintings
Finger Paintings and others on the walls
that we see in nurseries and homes
around the world juxtaposed with the
empty beds the empty cots the clothes
lined up shows that these are not
numbers
these are not politics these are not
belligerents these are the most innocent
part of the creation of God which are
children and this compels the need for
us to come together work
concretely to make the law
more effective
children and it's been a continuous
focus of my own mandate try to put them
more in the spotlight
it was after all a year ago on Friday
that the maripole theater
was bombed
with reports of hundreds of
deaths many children
there are cultured reports of maternity
Wards and hospitals being attacked
so in the noise that is
inevitable
we should focus on what really is taking
place and the need to have independent
and partial investigations create a
record that can then be tested by the
defense tested and scrutinized by judges
to create a record that will stand the
test of time over the past year the
whole approach
in fact since my appointment since my
election it's a realization that we
can't do this alone
so Partnerships such as this absolutely
key joint investigative teams with your
adjust with national authorities the
wonderful example of the forensic
rotational model by the Royal
Netherlands Massachusetts the need to
engage actively with civil society with
eurojust with the genocide Network by
way of the guidance that we distributed
are all examples of us moving forward
and I think if I may say so the the
comment of the Minister of Justice and
also the Deputy Prime Minister deserve
reflection
if we don't at this moment in world
affairs cling to the law if we don't
look at ourselves and decide how we can
do better not just in Ukraine but as
Nations as member states of the United
Nations we will not only miss an
opportunity but we may not have further
opportunities I think this needs to be a
moment where we realize if we don't
cling to the law we may have nothing to
cling to in the future we can't be
complacent and think peace prosperity
economic advancement is the inevitable
Birthright of every child and every
country so the law needs to become more
relevant and I really do applaud
at this initiative in terms of concrete
steps that we can do better for victims
around the world that also crave the
shelter of the law if we keep our eyes
on the suffering of humanity
in rooms as August as this I think maybe
this in the brickness of Ukraine in the
suffering of Ukraine maybe we can do in
these few moments we have on this Earth
better
for the future generations to come and
finally
give some solidity
to the promise of never again so I look
forward to your support and your
interactions and really commend today in
this really necessary however
regrettable initiative thank you so much
Karim eloquently and very powerfully put
please may I turn now to the European
commissioner for justice his Excellency
DDA reindeers Didier the floor is yours
thank you Dominican I want to thank you
and to thank data and maybe uh to uh UK
and the Netherlands for organizing this
conference it's a very important moment
about the support of the ICC and it's my
pleasure dear colleagues ladies and
gentlemen to be present here today to
reaffirm the European Union's
long-standing support for the invaluable
work of the international criminal court
and most recently in the context of the
war in Ukraine and for more than a year
now Russia's war of aggression as
disregard the foundations of all
International rules-based order and
destroyed the lives of many it is
against this background that the ICC a
step up it's a fault in investigating
the international crimes that are being
committed on Ukraine soil on a daily
basis it's clear that when it comes to
preventing impunity for the more serious
crimes committed during this war the
international criminal court Remains the
key International actor to investigate
and prosecute the perpetrators
for this reason that since the beginning
of Russian's war of aggression the urban
commission is provided over 10 million
euro in support of the icc's work on
Ukraine and let me assure you the
European Union stands ready to continue
providing the necessary support as a
situation in Ukraine deserves a response
that is up to the task
financing decision was recently adapted
on to continue an au support project to
the ICC which is scheduled for 2025 and
will Encompass the amounts of 3 million
euro in addition the commission Council
and member states has been discussing a
John coordination and follow-up to the
request report by the office of the
prosecutor
in light of the above I welcome and
encourage the pledges by member states
to provide further support which will be
which will hear more about later today
but let there be no mistake in all
struggle to ensure that Justice is
served for Ukraine and its people or a
fraud cannot stop at providing the
necessary financial support we also need
to coordinate our investigative efforts
in respect to the international crimes
committed in Ukraine in March last year
geologists supported the setup of the
joint investigation team in order to
coordinate National investigations on
International crimes committed to the
Ukraine and for the first time ever the
ICC is participating in a joint
investigation team which facilitates
Swift and efficient coordination with
Ukraine and six member states as jit
members another crucial development is
the setup of the future International
Center for the prosecution of the crime
evacuation against recreate which will
be embedded in the current John
investigation team
the icpa will provide a structure for
enhanced cooperation on the collection
preservation and Analysis of evidence
related to the tribe of migration for
any future trial
ultimately we need to look ahead to
ensure that the ICC can effectively
perform its function in the context of
the current crisis of today and the
crisis of Tomorrow this also enters the
need for the International Community to
strengthen the ICC traditional regime
over the most serious International
crimes including for the crime of
aggression and it's very important to
insist on the role of the ICC in such a
kind of situation and in order to pursue
the subjective the commission underlies
the necessity to amend the Rome Statute
in order to enable the ICC to exercise
jurisdiction over the crime evacuation
for this reason the justice and home
Affairs Council of the 10th of March
this year I invited the member states to
continue reflecting on this important
And Timely endeavorable
in the short term the establishment of
any potential accountability mechanisms
for the prosecution of the crime
immigration in Ukraine should respect
the icc's Mandate and traditional
Primacy
finally the commission and the member
states have continuously called on
Ukraine to ratify the Rome statute such
a decision would bring Ukrainian
national legislation in line with
International standards and Provisions
thereby strengthening the international
rules-based order for current and future
generations of ukrainians let me
conclude by saying this
why sing is clear there can be no
impunity for the international crimes
committed in Ukraine including the crime
of aggression
I'm therefore convinced that is our role
as an International Community to bring
those responsible for these atrocities
to Justice
and prosecutor came candy Karim be
assured that you can count on the
commission's full support in achieving
this goal we will support all decisions
already taken including about
deportation of children or to be taken
in full independence by the court it's
important to do that not only due to the
situation in Ukraine but also the
situation in many other places in the
world and I'm very pleased to see
participants from all over the world
around the table and will continue to be
engaged in such a support for the ICC in
all the possible situations where war
crimes are committed thank you very much
for the opportunity to confirm the
support that we are giving of course to
the ICC and certainly to the prosecutor
General
thank you so much very well said
um before I come to our next speaker can
I just check um or in part really for
those that may wish interpretation
during the course of the day channel one
is English Channel Two is French channel
three is in Spanish now it gives me a a
great pleasure but it's also a great
honor to ask the Minister of Justice for
Ukraine Dennis maluska to speak to us
Dennis can I say how warmly welcome you
are here today and how we want to do
everything to support you in the
challenges you face
thank you and dear colleagues dear
friends we've became friends with many
of you during the last year and of
course
I would start with the words of
appreciation for the governments of UK
the UK and the Netherlands for the
initiative for the assistance and I do
remember
quite a year ago when we had the first
meeting similar meeting in Hague when
all countries gathered together to
discuss how U.S ICC activity could be
supported by member states and I was
invited I participate there and I'm
really great that
really glad that we remain strong and
determined in the assistance and the
support for ACC
since
now we are sure and we could show that
not only military International
cooperation which brought tangible
results is
available and Broad results but also
International legal cooperation also
brought significant tangible results
and we had a historic event last Friday
with the arrest warrant when ICC showed
that rule of law prevails no matter what
and this story of course has also a flip
side a darker side
which shows that even the president of a
country permanent member of U.N security
Council could be a war criminal
which shows that this movement is not
only historic but tragic as well
and as we discussed with my friend Marco
Bushman just an hour ago
uh this we could say definitely say that
it's not ICC on our website only crane
side since ICC is neutral and
independent organization but it's rule
of law on our side
we abide by rules we respect Geneva
conventions
we abide by ICC
mandate and we support and recognize
jurisdiction of ICC on the Crane's
territory we domesticated Rome statute
and we indeed have a huge respect for
the rule of law and we are happy that we
could show
our people Ukrainian society that rule
of all matters that these are not just
simple words or even values but this is
something material something meaningful
and something which could change our
lives we could which could be a game
changer in the war
when it's clear who is right and who is
wrong
even if the whole Russian brainwashing
machine is used throughout the world
we see the sign and we appreciate your
assistance your assistance to ICC and to
Ukraine as well without your support we
would not survive I won't be here I
won't feel and won't be able to
represent a sovereign Ukrainian country
without our allies without our partners
and we also understand that you give
that support not because we just good
people or we are a good country but also
because we confirm and we respect rule
of law
and PR on the bright side
of those who fight the war
I would also like to use this
opportunity to say a couple of words
on our initiative since the Criminal
part of
uh
to responds to the Russian aggression is
a significant one but not the only one
there are many people whose
were
really who suffered significant damages
who those are relatives husbands and
wives homes jobs
many municipalities who lost their
infrastructure
the whole country was
semi-destroyed by the
Russian activities and
those damages shall be compensated
and our initiative apart from the
support to ICC and criminal
investigations apart from support to
creation of tribunal and the work of
joint investigation team also envisages
creation of a compensation fund to
compensate for damages the first step
creation of register for damages is
already in progress on the way and we
would be glad to start the work of the
register and relevant initiative to
launch relevant initiative quite soon in
recent month
uh but the next steps creation of
compensation Commission
and also compensation fund filled in
with Russian assets is up to you to
support and up to you to help us to
create
and we would really be glad to see your
support in that area as well this is
really important to us since we have and
we will have after the war is over after
our week three
really damaged country with significant
demographic economic
and
also psychological problems related to
the war and we need to make Ukraine
prosper
and that would
require significant preparations
and finally
I would just ask you and returning back
to the topic of this conference
to support
icc's activity
with any resources needed to that
institution that is important
we understand
that you are on the side of the rule of
law
and
we promise you to keep
respecting and keep complying with
International humanitarian law so that
all your arrest warrants and all your
actions will be against Russia but not
Ukraine since we are decent
people decent Army
and we
would be glad to keep doing that and
Achieve clean Victory without any
violation and we really appreciate your
work your Independence your neutrality
and your resentfulness thank you
Denise thank you very much and very
powerful uh Speech can I finally uh
drown up the opening speeches ask Andrew
costin prosecutor general of Ukraine to
say a few words
thank you thank you Deputy Prime
Minister
morning
ladies and gentlemen and as my fellow
colleague and friend Denise maduska
absolutely
um
pointed out
the friends of Ukraine because everyone
who are here
to support our
fight for justice for ukrainians for
Ukraine and for all of the democratic
values of freedom and sovereignty are
our
true friends and I'm delighted to be
with you today and to be a witness of
the Monumental instance in the history
of international Justice
prosecutor Han at the United for Justice
Conference in leaf three weeks ago
said that we are living in the war of
values
the issuance of an arrest warrant
against Putin by pre-trial chamber of
the international criminal court is
nothing else but the
unequivocal affirmation that
notwithstanding all the pressure and
attempts of disruption of the
international justice system the office
of prosecutor and the court stand as
guardians of justice and those that
allow themselves to commit International
crimes will not go unpunished
in this slide our meeting today is
extremely timely and pertinent
at the outset
I wish to thank the United Kingdom and
Deputy Prime Minister Secretary of State
for justice and Lord Chancellor Dominic
Rapp
for their immense and unwavering support
that you have been providing to Ukraine
I also would like to underscore the role
of the Netherlands and personally the
Minister of Justice
and securityus
in supporting us but also embedding
experts into the international criminal
court and further facilitating its work
fruits of which we are all admiring
today
I'm grateful for all of the states that
have been there for Ukraine as well as
assisting and strengthening the court
our meeting today is clear at the
station that Justice is the fundamental
ideal of our societies
there is no fair and Equitable world
without Justice
Russian aggression against Ukraine which
is ongoing for
390 days apart from being a flagrant
violation of territorial integrity and
sovereignty is also characterized by
ruthless
attacks against civilians and
residential areas along with the
commission of widespread and systematic
atrocities
there is no a single day without
residential areas or buildings being
attacked directly and intentionally
causing immense suffering and death
among civilians
several days ago we all commemorated
those that cruelly perished
during the bombing of the mariopal drama
theater
we are still unable to fully investigate
this he knows crime as mariopal is still
under the occupation
Russia x with a clear plan to destroy
Ukraine and Ukrainian identity and
unlawful deportation and transfer of
thousands of Ukrainian children
including from orphanages
and Care Homes to Russia
simplifying their illegal adoption
process and conferring them citizenship
of an aggressor state is one but a very
clear manifestation of this plan
this is done to cut ties with Ukraine
and alter their Ukrainian identity
my office
has already launched investigation into
over 72
000 incidents of war crimes
far from isolated or sporadic acts we
see how Russian food soldiers are
meticulously implementing unlawful
orders given from Kremlin
in this circumstances only joint efforts
at International and domestic level we
will manage to efficiently respond to
the policy of force and human suffering
displayed by Russia and eliminating any
opportunity for the safe havens for war
criminals
international criminal court is an
indispensable pillar in this process of
achieving Justice and International
Peace and security
Ukraine has been closely working with
the court from the beginning of Russian
aggression
we have amended legislation to ensure
steady cooperation framework with the
court and smooth operation of their
representative on the territory of
Ukraine
moreover
in three days
we will sign an agreement between the
ICC and Ukraine on the establishment of
the ICC field office in Ukraine which
hopefully will take this cooperation
into another level
we are working with courts enhance
skills of our law enforcement officers
only several days ago we concluded a
comprehensive training on integrated
witness and victim-centered model for
protection and support for victims of
the conflict related sexual violence
by the end of this month we will
conclude the process of establishment of
the victims and Witnesses coordination
unit as well as increase of the
inter-agency and CSO coordination
bearing all this in mind
allow me to quote president zielinski
when he referred to the issuance of the
arrest warrants
he noted that this historic decision now
entails historic responsibilities
the court just made a might fall but the
initial step towards holding accountable
those responsible for the commission of
international crimes
getting a suspect into the dock of the
ICC could be a challenge
especially when a warrant is issued
against an incumbent head of the
non-state party
therefore now the burden is on states to
closely cooperate with the court
and in Synergy device bespoke solutions
to overcome these challenges
simultaneously we should not allow for
the crime of aggression to go unpunished
yes international criminal court might
be jurisdictionary constraint in
relation to this crime
this however should not stop us from
striving to attain comprehensive Justice
in this regard I call upon you to
support the idea of the establishment of
the international Tribunal for the
investigation and the prosecution of the
crime of aggression
which is a leadership crime
and which will ensure linkage to the
highest political and military leaders
in Russia Today Putin
is suspected
on commission of war crimes War crime in
Ukraine
this war crime could not
have been committed if crime of
aggression was not committed by Putin
and his
surrounding for many ukrainians now who
understand that Putin is suspect at the
ICC
they say he's already suspect for the
crime of aggression
even if we still have no instrument to
prosecute this on International level
and this is very important for all of us
I would like to
personally command
the work of
Kareem Han
his
team
in Ukraine
shoulder to shoulder with our
prosecutors and investigators
his team in The Hague
all of our experts involved
this was really a great job done by many
many professionals
who believe that Justice
is worse everything
and I really
would like to ask
for any
possible assistance
for their Karim and his team
and I also want to say something I don't
know if it is
good to say this within this audience
but for me
as prosecutor general of Ukraine
the country which state
authorities and all law enforcement
agencies were active from the very first
day of War
for me
it's very important that the first case
brought before the ICC with regard to
International crimes committed in
Ukraine
was the case where ICC
explicitly played its complementary role
with regard to all the cases we are
Prosecuting in Ukraine because we can't
reach Putin because of personal immunity
and this is a thank you Karim for this
because this is very important for my
prosecutors you know how
how they work
and for them it's very important that
the first case was a really
complementary one
and we will definitely go ahead I told
many of you we have a lot of plans
but in order these plans to be executed
of course we need support not only we in
Ukraine but of course the team of Kareem
in order to go ahead and to show more
and more results which will
really
open the door
for real trust in international serve
International International Justice
which will serve in time
this is very important for all of us and
of course for victims and survivors of
war crimes
I would like to
conclude with the
quote of President Eisenhower
he said Peace and Justice are two sides
of the same coin
to achieve one we have to attain the
other
and one thing we all agree
that the international criminal court is
the key to this thank you my dear
colleagues and Friends
but thank you so much uh uh Denise and
Andre for both uh your Clarion call to
action but also for giving us a very
clear sense of how you're working with
the ICC
um friends I think it's uh time uh to
take a break but can I just give you
three housekeeping points very quickly
uh before I do
um we're going to go and take a photo uh
in the uh Grand Hall staircase can I
just ask that delegates allow ministers
and heads of Delegation to leave first
so we can get that done then we will
have lunch and can I ask everyone to
come back for 1 15 just so you should
already be brief but there'll be two
sessions in the afternoon one on
evidence Gathering which I will chair
and then one on witness support that
Dylan will chair I look forward to
seeing you back here then and I hope you
enjoy lunch thank you